[Musique]
imaginez-vous dans ville du coin une
petite ville de carrés et de triangles
avec d'autres polygones aussi situé dans
une énorme pleine la mairie vient de
décider de la construction d'un nouveau
musée des maths mais il reste à décider
ou construire ce musée chaque polygone a
en tête une position idéale du musée et
bon plus souvent ça revient à le plus
près possible de chez elle ou de chez
lui mais comme les polygones de la ville
du coin habitent aux quatre coins de la
ville et même souvent au-delà dans la
région dans des maisons de campagne
éloignées des préférences des différents
polygones sont clairement conflictuelles
qui plus est même si ces polygones sont
gentils il est elles sont souvent avant
tout des mathématiciens et
mathématiciennes et ne peuvent donc pas
s'empêcher de se comporter de manière
stratégique en particulier ne serait-ce
que pour le défi intellectuel les
polygones sont prêts à mentir sur leur
préférence de position géographiques du
musée si cela leur permet de rapprocher
le musée de leur position préférentielle
et alors parmi les polygones il y a
quelques théoriciens des jeux qui savent
très bien que si on suit un vote par
agenda ou un scrutin par une suite de
référendum alors on peut facilement se
retrouver dans une décision finale en
fait catastrophique pour la plupart des
citoyens c'était aussi un des jeux de
vie du coin connaissent aussi très bien
les solutions démocratiques les plus
connues comme par exemple le jugement
majoritaire et le scooter de Condorcet
endomisé cependant ces solutions ne
fonctionnent que s'il y a un nombre fini
de position possible et même un nombre
assez faible de position possible du
musée des mathématiques or le musée dans
notre cas on peut le vraiment le
construire n'importe où dans la plaie il
y a une infinité de position candidate
pour le musée et ça les scrutins
classiques pareil ils sont pas très bons
pour traiter ce cas mais donc comment
déterminer démocratiquement le lieu de
construction du musée quel est le
scrutin le plus adéquat à adopter pour
ville du coin et par ailleurs quel est
le rapport entre ce problème purement
théorique et la sécurité des
intelligences artificielles
les algorithmes de machine learning les
plus impressionnants d'aujourd'hui qu'il
s'agisse de chaque GPT de Middle journée
ou de l'algorithme de recommandations de
Tik Tok tous s'appuient sur des réseaux
de neurones qui sont des sortes de
grosses machines avec un très grand
nombre de paramètres à ajuster et comme
on en a beaucoup parlé dans la série sur
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
paramètres sont ajustés à partir des
données très concrètement pour chaque
donnée l'apprentissage de la donnée par
l'algorithme de machine learning
correspond à une direction de
modification des paramètres de
l'algorithme qu'on appelle aussi le
gradient le gradient dit pour chaque
paramètre à quel point il est très
simple de tourner ce paramètre en fait
plus précisément ce gradient est aussi à
chaque paramètre un nombre positif ou
négatif qui dit à quel point il faut
augmenter ou diminuer le réglage actuel
du paramètre dans le cas d'un algorithme
à deux paramètres le gradient associe à
chacun des deux paramètres un taux
auquel il faut le tourner si bien que la
direction de modification des paramètres
est alors une paire de deux nombres
si on interprète maintenant ces nombres
comme les coordonnées d'un point on peut
alors placer dans un plan le déplacement
adéquat des paramètres et pour rappel se
déplacement adéquat est associé à une
donnée si bien que si on veut que
l'algorithme apprenne de toutes les
données auxquelles il a accès il va
falloir combiner les déplacements
adéquats selon chacune des données vous
voyez le lien avec la position du musée
de ville du coin déterminez où placée un
musée pour les polygones aux préférences
divergentes de ville du coin c'est
finalement très similaire à déterminer
comment permettre un réseau de neurones
d'apprendre de plusieurs données
différentes sauf que dans le cas du
machine learning et contrairement aux
coordonnées GPS tu as envie du coin les
granulés sont concrètement ne liste de
nombres dans un espace de très grandes
dimensions autant de dimensions qu'il y
a de paramètres dans le modèle de
machine learning
et alors en pratique dans la
quasi-totalité des algorithmes de
machines learning si souvent déployés
avec beaucoup plus d'attention pour la
spectacularité voire la hype que sa
engendrer que pour la sécurité la
solution pour agréger les déplacements
adéquats selon toutes les données
revient à prendre la moyenne des
déplacements suggérés par chaque donnée
et là vous voyez peut-être venir le
problème en pratique les données
utilisées pour entraîner les algorithmes
sont rarement sécurisés par exemple
chaque GPT s'appuie sur les textes
publiés sur Reddit midjorni généralise
les images du web et l'algorithme de Tik
Tok s'appuie sur les clics et les swipe
des utilisateurs autrement dit toutes
ces données viennent de fournisseurs
très fiables qu'on appelle aussi des
internautes
internaute pour appel c'est pas
forcément très fiable
première vidéo de cette série et au fait
que chaque année Facebook retire autour
de 6 milliards de fonte en particulier à
l'instar des polygones de ville du coin
ces internautes peuvent se comporter de
manière stratégique surtout si des
influenceurs encouragent ces
comportements stratégiques à toutes
leurs communautés alors rien à voir mais
pensez bien à liker à commenter et à
partager cette vidéo et à vous abonner à
la chaîne ainsi qu'à mettre la cloche et
si vous avez plusieurs comptes Google
pensez le faire avec chacun de vos
comptes Google ce comportement pas
forcément naturel pourrait vraiment
aider cette vidéo en fait aujourd'hui
quand on parle notamment le livre
toxique data de David chavalarias il
existe des énormes industries de la
désinformation et du coup il serait
irréaliste de supposer que les données
qui alimentent l'apprentissage des
intelligences artificielles les plus
puissantes du monde moderne ne sont pas
produites de manière stratégique le web
est un environnement extrêmement
adversarial mais donc dans ce contexte
adversarial voir deux guerres
informationsnel du web est-ce que la
moyenne est une solution adéquate pour
agréger différentes directions est-ce
qu'elle provoque les bons incitatifs et
bien clairement non en effet en
exagérant la position où il préfère
placer le musée chaque polygone peut
tirer la décision finale vers sa
position préférée la moyenne encourage
en fait l'expression de préférence plus
extrême que les vrais préférences des
parties prenantes pour les polygones de
ville du coin tout comme pour les
internautes qui veulent influencer le
comportement des algorithmes les plus
influents du web
l'intuition selon laquelle on se mettant
plus loin les polygones peuvent tirer
plus fort sur la position du musée est
en fait tout à fait formalisable
imaginons qu'on laisse un caillou en
plein centre-ville de ville du coin et
que chaque polygone attache une ficelle
au cailloux puis chaque plus gone se
place au niveau de la position qu'il dit
préférée et supposons enfin que chaque
polygone tire le caillou vers lui avec
une force proportionnelle à la distance
qui le sépare du caillou alors la
moyenne correspondra exactement à la
position d'équilibre c'est à dire à la
position du caillou tel que les forces
avec lesquelles les différents polygones
tirent sur le caillou s'annule
et bon ça je ne vais pas le démontrer
mathématiquement ici mais j'invite les
matos parmi vous à le faire du point de
vue de la théorie des jeux cette
situation est clairement très
insatisfaisante elle montre très bien à
quel point la moyenne induit des
incitatives problématiques il suffit en
effet de se placer plus loin pour
acquérir littéralement plus de pouvoir
sur la position du caillot on peut par
ailleurs y voir une certaine forme
d'iniquité d'une certaine manière avec
la moyenne les positions les plus
extrêmes sont davantage valorisées
puisque ceux qui les adoptent auront
plus d'influence sur la position du
musée ou sur les paramètres et donc le
comportement de l'algorithme de machine
learning et bien c'est ce constat qui a
poussé à des collègues de l'EPFL et moi
a proposé un scrutin plus juste qui
s'appuie sur un principe à la fois très
simple et à mon sens très élégant qui
dit tout simplement que chaque polygone
tire sur le caillou avec toujours une
même force unitaire indépendamment de la
distance qui le sépare du caillou
autrement dit on a tout simplement
formalisé le principe d'équité un
électeur une force unitaire un principe
qui s'est depuis retrouvé au cœur des
algorithmes de tournesol en fait pour
tout vous dire on est un peu
complètement réinventer la roue ce qu'on
obtient en appliquant le principe que je
viens dénoncer correspond en fait un
objet mathématique bien connu et même
connu depuis fort longtemps puisqu'il
est connu il y a plusieurs siècles dans
certains pierres de faire map et puis il
a été réétudié notamment par l'économie
c'était géographe Alfred Weber qui est
le frère du sociologue max et qu'il a
appliqué notamment dans un cadre de
minimisation de transport en effet on
peut démontrer et là encore je la ça en
démonstration en exercice pour les
matheux parmi vous que le processus où
chaque mathématicien tire le caillou
avec une même force unitaire conduit
essentiellement toujours un unique point
d'équilibre qui a par ailleurs la
propriété de minimiser la somme des
distances entre ce point et les
positions préférées des différents
mathématiciens d'où le lien avec la
théorie du transport optimal en fait le
seul cas où ce point d'équilibre n'est
pas unique c'est lorsque les polygones
sont en nombre pair et sont alignés le
long d'une droite à ce moment là tous
les points du segment qui sépare les
deux polygones du milieu correspondent à
des points d'équilibre ou une moitié des
polygones tirs d'un côté et l'autre
moitié tire de l'autre côté en fait en
dimension 1 toute position d'équilibre
de notre processus sépare nécessairement
l'ensemble des polygones en deux
ensembles de même taille
et là les plus perspicaces parmi vous
voit peut-être venir la chose en
dimension 1 un point est une position
d'équilibre de notre processus si et
seulement si il est une médiane des
positions préférées des mathématiciens
ainsi l'équilibre du processus qu'on
décrit notamment dans les dimensions
supérieures et bien une généralisation
de la médiane en dimension 1 et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'appelle plus communément
la médiane géométrique et parce qu'elle
correspond aux résultats d'un processus
qui paraît intuitivement juste il semble
s'agir d'un excellent candidat pour être
le scrutin que les polygones devraient
adopter pour choisir collaborativement
la localisation géographique du musée et
ça semble aussi un bon candidat à
utiliser pour la conception
d'algorithmes de machine learning pour
le web pour éviter que les utilisateurs
n'exagèrent leur préférence en fait la
médiane géométrique est vraiment le
scrutin que je recommande dans d'autres
applications par exemple si vous voulez
voter démocratiquement la répartition
d'un budget pour différents départements
où la location d'un fond philanthropique
à différents organismes récipients
en parlant de gouvernance je tiens à
remercier chaleureusement infomaniaque
le sponsor est partenaire de
l'association tournesol contrairement à
Google Amazon ou Microsoft Infomaniak
est une entreprise suisse et elle n'est
donc pas sous le coup du Patriote Act
qui force les entreprises américaines à
partager des données de clients avec les
services de renseignement américain à
leur demande en privilégiant Infomaniak
à ces entreprises américaines vous
protéger ainsi vos données et les
données de vos clients Infomaniak offre
toute une suite de services Cloud allant
de l'hébergement de site web à des
services de stockage de données de
visioconférence ou de forums que
l'association tournesol utilise
désormais merci beaucoup à Infomaniak
pour leur contribution à notre projet
associatif je tiens à préciser qu'il ne
me paie pas directement il paie
uniquement l'association à but non
lucratif tournesol
les chercheurs en sécurité du machine
learning n'ont en fait pas attendu notre
article pour utiliser la médiane
géométrique pour sécuriser
l'apprentissage des machines mais est-ce
vraiment là une bonne solution en
particulier la médiane géométrique
encourage-t-elle vraiment les polygones
à exprimer leurs vrais préférence pour
la position du musée
il y a trois ans j'étais tellement
persuadé que la réponse à cette question
était oui que je l'ai laissé en exercice
d'échauffement pour un étudiant en
Master donc j'encadrer le stage de
recherche et sur qui je comptais pour
des questions de recherche beaucoup plus
poussées que celle-ci après tout me
disait si je préfère que le musée soit
proche de chez moi j'ai tout intérêt à
le tirer vers chez moi non
en particulier clairement je n'ai pas
intérêt à exagérer mes préférences
puisque je tirerais toujours avec la
même direction mais en aucun cas je ne
tirerais plus fort comme le disait mon
prof de prépa ça se sent bien ça doit se
montrer facilement non et bien non après
plusieurs semaines l'étudiant a fini par
douter que la réponse était oui et on a
ensuite fini par démontrer que la
réponse était non et je peux d'ailleurs
vous montrer un contre exemple où ce
n'est pas le cas c'est à dire une
situation ou un polygone à intérêt à
mentir sur la position du musée qu'il
préfère imaginez trois polygones
triangles losange et shilogone un
chiotone c'est un polygone à 1000 côtés
notamment imaginé par Descartes pour
défiler notre capacité à visualiser
certains objets mathématiques bon bref
supposer que triangle et losanges habite
à ses prennent de l'autre mais que shill
yougon habite très loin presque à
l'infini dans la configuration à l'écran
vous pouvez voir que la médiane
géométrique sera un point telle que les
angles à l'écran c'est à dire les angles
entre les un bout d'officielle font tous
un tiers de Tours en effet on voit alors
que les forces unitaires avec lesquelles
triangle losange et shillogones tirent
sur la position du musée vont bien
s'annuler puisqu'il y a une symétrie de
rotation parfaite entre les trois et
bien à bien y réfléchir on peut se
rendre compte que losange peut
rapprocher la médiane géométrique en
préférant préféré un point un peu plus
haut à droite à l'image en effet si
losange affirme préféré cet autre point
la médiane géométrique glissera le long
de la droite à l'écran notamment si on
suppose que shilogone est tellement loin
que sa force unitaire demeurera toujours
quasiment parfaitement vers la droite en
effet la force de triangle est inchangée
alors que celle de losange aussi
puisqu'on a simplement translaté le cas
de figure précédent sauf que là patatras
la médiane géométrique s'est rapproché
de la vraie position préférée de losange
un petit calcul trigonométrique montre
même qu'on s'est rapproché d'un facteur
sinus de 1/6 de tour ce qui correspond à
racine carrée de 3 / 2 soit environ 8
15% de la distance initiale en montant
sur ses préférences losange a ainsi
réduit la distance entre chez lui et le
musée de 13%. ok ça m'a déjà beaucoup
surpris il y a des cas où la médiane
géométrique ne favorise pas le netteté
mais est-ce là le pire cas peut-on
imaginer des cas où en montant sur ses
préférences losange peut gagner un
facteur
50%, voire
99%. bien si le stagiaire peut
l'encadrer n'a malheureusement pas eu le
temps de répondre à ces questions il a
suffisamment clarifier le problème pour
m'aider à mieux le comprendre mais aussi
et surtout pour m'aider à embarquer dans
le projet d'autres chercheurs notamment
elmadian Hamdi professeur à l'École
polytechnique mais aussi et surtout
l'excellent doctorant Sadek farad Kani
de l'EPFL et ensemble on a réussi à
démontrer qu'il n'y avait pas de bornes
sur ce qu'un polygone pouvait gagner il
existe ainsi des cas ou un polygone peut
réduire la distance au musée de
99,99% en montant sur sa localisation
préférée et plus généralement pour tout
est psilon strictement positif il existe
une situation où le polygone peut
réduire la distance entre le musée et
chez lui d'un facteur un mois Epsilon en
montant sur sa vraie préférence avec la
médiane géométrique il existe des cas ou
mentir sur ses préférences est un
incitatif énorme
alors en effet il y a des cas tordus où
les incitatifs à mentir sur énorme mais
ces cas attendus sont-ils ceux qu'on
rencontre en pratique comment quantifier
les incitatifs à mentir dans des cas
plus réalistes telles sont les questions
qui nous animèrent ensuite avec à
nouveau cette intuition que si la
médiane géométrique peut faire survenir
des bizarreries en termes d'incitatifs
celle-ci reste des cas extrêmes et
peut-être peu réaliste pour formaliser
cette intuition nous avons proposé
d'étudier le cas où ville du coin est
extrêmement peuplé et où les préférences
des nombreux polygones de la ville sont
naturellement décrites par une
distribution de préférence en fait comme
les vrais mathématiciens que nous sommes
on a même fait le cheminement inverse en
supposant au préalable une distribution
de préférence puis en considérant que
les préférences de chaque polygone de
vie du coin était tirés au hasard de
cette distribution de préférence voilà
qui nous permet en particulier de fixer
un cadre asympiotique ou dans la limite
d'un grand nombre de citoyens la
distribution empirique des préférences
de ses citoyens collent vraiment
vraiment pas mal avec la distribution
théorique initiale bon désolé d'être un
peu technique c'est un peu le retour des
mathématiques sur scène for all et bon à
partir de maintenant tout ne sera pas
forcément très simple la question qu'on
se pose ensuite est la suivante quand le
nombre de citoyens est suffisamment
grand ne peut donc pas démontrer que les
incitatifs à mentir seront
nécessairesment limités notamment par
des propriétés de la distribution
théorique des préférences et bien le
théorème principal que nous avons
démontré et que la réponse à cette
question est oui et on a même fourni une
quantification des incitatifs à mentir
de façon intrigante ces incitatifs
dépendent d'une forme de polarisation de
la distribution des préférences dans le
cas d'une distribution isotrope où
toutes les directions sont aussi
polarisées les unes que les autres ces
incisives à mentir sont toujours quasi
nuls cependant si la distribution est
polarisée dans une direction et beaucoup
plus consensuelle dans d'autres
directions peut-être parce que certaines
directions correspond typiquement je
sais pas la réforme des retraites alors
que l'autre direction correspond à
est-ce que il est normal pour les chats
d'avoir quatre pattes alors les
incitatifs à mentir peuvent être très
importants pour certains polygones en
fait les citoyens auront intérêt à
paraître plus polarisés encore dans la
direction polarisée et le plus
consensuel dans la direction
consensuelle c'est comme si les citoyens
devaient faire un choix conscient de
choisir leur bataille et de se
concentrer uniquement sur les sujets
polarisés notre article montre par
ailleurs des manières d'atténuer ses
incitatifs notamment en gros on
valorisant différemment les différentes
directions de façon plus précise on
propose de tordre la médiane géométrique
en pénalisant les forces selon certaines
directions ou de manière équivalente
ceci revient à imposer des forces
unitaires mais selon des normes pseudo
euclidiennes l'article parle aussi du
cas où les préférences des citoyens sont
elles-mêmes non isotropes c'est-à-dire
que pour ses citoyens être proche selon
certaines directions et beaucoup plus
important qu'être proche selon d'autres
directions quoi qu'il en soit chez le
grand plaisir de vous dire que cet
article a récemment été accepté dans le
prestigieuse conférence et Aristote 2023
où il a été présenté par le génial Sadek
hard Kany dont vous pouvez voir
d'ailleurs une présentation de notre
article sur YouTube
cette recherche sur la médiane
géométrique restera l'un des plus beaux
travaux que j'aurais effectués non
seulement parce que les mathématiques
étaient particulièrement belles avec
notamment des calculs de tenseurs
différentiel du troisième ordre utile
pour démontrer la convexité de certains
régions de l'espace le tout dans un
total d'environ 40 pages de preuves ce
qui a la preuve la plus longue que j'ai
jamais écrites mais aussi que après un
article sur condenseur misé il
s'agissait de l'un de mes premiers
travaux théoriques avec de vraies
conséquences pratiques d'ailleurs j'ai
vraiment envie de vous présenter les
idées de démonstration de nos théorèmes
et peut-être que je le ferai dans une
vidéo hardcore si vous êtes notamment
beaucoup à vous manifester pour le
demander cette vidéo gros problème au
moment c'est que je monte de tort mais
c'est vrai que c'est tentant en même
temps est-ce que ça fera des vues ça
dépend de vous mettez les commentaires
en description si vous voulez cette
vidéo hardcore bon après ça va peut-être
vous décevoir mais notre article m'aura
surtout convaincu de ne pas utiliser la
médiane géométrique pour la conception
des algorithmes de tournesol après tout
même si les gains mentir sont en
pratique limitée la stratégie optimale
si on se permet de biaiser nos
préférences Ré à savoir polariser
davantage dans les aspects déjà
polarisés ça me paraît si intuitif et si
facile à adopter et si dangereux en
pratique pour la qualité des données
ainsi collectées il m'a semblé
préférable d'adopter des solutions plus
robustes aux manipulations stratégiques
comme la médiane par coordonnée rien
qu'en gros pour chaque coordonnées on va
calculer la médiane des scores rapportés
par les utilisateurs bon en fait si on a
changé les algorithmes de tournesol ça
vient aussi surtout d'une motivation qui
dépasse le cadre de cette vidéo avec
notamment une histoire de parisien
mécontent et de Marseillais dans
l'exagération et donc je finirai
clairement par vous parler sur scène
forum mais bon même si j'aimerais bien
récupérer mon rythme de production avant
je ne garantis pas de date pour la
sortie d'une telle vidéo ceci étant dit
je suis très loin d'avoir enterré la
médiane géométrique même si elle s'est
fait exclure du coeur des algorithmes de
tournesol certaines de ses propriétés
remarquables comme le fait qu'elle
appartient nécessairement à l'enveloppe
convexe des propositions des différents
polygones de ville du coin en font un
candidat parfait pour d'autres
applications comme le sécurisé sur
lequel j'aimerais tellement avoir plus
de temps pour travailler sérieusement ça
va faire deux ans que j'ai les grandes
idées de comment faire un vote parisien
sécurisé qui permettrait notamment de
corriger les biais parmi les personnes
qui se sont exprimées dans le vote et je
vous manque cruellement de temps pour
vérifier que le vote que j'ai en tête à
les propriétés que je veux qu'il ait et
d'ailleurs s'il y a des motivé parmi
vous pour investiguer ce sujet n'hésitez
surtout pas à me contacter pour en
savoir plus même si bon c'est un peu
nécessaire que vous soyez très à l'aise
en mathématiques vous serez typiquement
au moins au niveau thèse en
mathématiques ou au niveau thèse en
informatique avec un grand penchant
mathématique par ailleurs la médiane
géométrique renforce déjà très
grandement la sécurité des algorithmes
de machine learning notamment vis-à-vis
de corruption volontaires ou
involontaire de la base de données
d'entraînement ce qui en pratique arrive
absolument tout le temps y compris dans
une base de données aussi basique et
incontournable que mist pour ceux qui
connaissent il y a des images avec des
fausses annotations dans la base de
données listes d'ailleurs si vous êtes
une entreprise qui fait de la datation
et si vous voulez que faire le point
pour vos équipes sur les mesures de
sécurité peu cher et efficaces à ajouter
pour renforcer la sécurité de vos
systèmes de machines learning vous serez
sans doute intéressé par les conférences
et le consulting que notre start-up
calica pas peut vous offrir comme on l'a
déjà fait à pas mal de groupe et donc si
vous êtes intéressé bah n'hésitez pas à
me contacter plus généralement la
conception des algorithmes
d'apprentissage vraiment démocratique
juste et sécurisé avec de surcroît de
bonnes propriétés d'incitatives mais
aussi de vérifier ou encore de
protection des informations sensibles en
plus d'être devenu une urgence pour la
sécurité de nos démocraties c'est
vraiment et de loin le plus fabuleux des
défis de recherche que je connaisse ce
fabuleux chantier implique d'ailleurs
aussi bien des aspects très
mathématiques comme celui de cette vidéo
ou des nombreuses autres questions de
recherche que j'ai dans ma to do list
que des défis d'implémentation et
d'interface utilisateurs voire des
problèmes de sociologie des
contributeurs de psychologie du vote ou
encore de philosophie politique morale
ou métal éthiques le tout incarné dans
un projet extrêmement concret quel
tournesol d'ailleurs je vous rappelle
qu'on a une expérience en cours sur
l'impact de tout mon sol sur les
utilisateurs donc si vous êtes un
utilisateurs notamment de l'extension de
tournesol je vous invite vivement à
participer à notre étude en répondant au
formulaire dont le lien est en
description je ne peux que vous
encourager à rejoindre notre fabuleux
chantier ou à nous aider à l'accomplir
en vous en parlant des questions de
recherche en contribuant un tournesol en
promouvant notre plateforme en demandant
aux influenceurs et aux médias dont
parler ou en effectuant des dons à notre
association à but non lucratif